this next story sounds like a satirical
story but it's not and it took me a few
days to get to it but I did want to just
mention it today the Trump department of
agriculture the USDA listed a fictional
country as a trade partner the USDA
listed Wakanda as a country that they
trade with now Wakanda does not exist
it's a fictional country that is from
the Marvel comic book universe it's an
imaginary country in I believe
sub-saharan Africa in the universe of
Marvel Comics is a fake country doesn't
really exist now here's the funniest
part the USDA says that it was added to
the list of countries during some kind
of test of their workers but hilariously
it wasn't just the country that was
listed it was also a it also listed were
a whole bunch of specific things that
Wakanda trades with the United States
including live purebred breeding cattle
and horses goats and sheep even guinea
fowl listed as something that Wakanda
and the United States trade now the
person who found this is a software
engineer named Francis Tseng who was
looking up agricultural tariffs for some
kind of application that he was working
on per the BBC the USDA spokesman has
explained to the Washington Post that
wakanda's listing internally was added
as a test file for staffers and was
never supposed to be public you know
this is just a funny dumb thing but I
love fake countries connected to the
Trump administration many of you
probably know where I'm going with this
my favorite was when Donald Trump made a
completely ignorant portmanteau of
Zambia and Namibia which he turned into
nambia
and said it multiple times in front of
African leaders remember this one and
I'm greatly honored to host this lunch
to be joined by the leaders of Cote
d'Ivoire Ethiopia Ghana Guinea nambia
Nigeria Senegal Uganda and South Africa
but we cannot have prosperity if we're
not healthy we will continue our
partnership on critical health
initiatives Uganda has made incredible
strides in the battle against hiv/aids
in Guinea and Nigeria you fought a
horrifying Ebola outbreak namby ha's
health system is increasingly
self-sufficient I actually like Cote
d'Ivoire even for whatever reason that
one and Ethiopia
I actually like almost as much as nambia
so I do believe that this was a mistake
I don't think that Donald Trump's USDA
is trying to pretend that trade
relations are better than they actually
are by listing fake countries but it is
very funny and Jimmy Kimmel did a very
funny thing where Jimmy went on the
street talking to people you I won't
play it because they are very aggressive
with copyright but if you go on YouTube
and you search for Jimmy Kimmel Wakanda
you will find one of those person on the
street segments where tons of people
believe that Wakanda is a real country
and this is not going to change that one
bit
now here's my question to you is that
crazy because what I mean is in Europe
lots of people likely don't know every
US state i've been to the west coast and
there are 20 year-olds on the west coast
who think massachusetts is made up
there's a lot of Europeans who probably
don't know every Central American
country for example maybe it's not crazy
that Americans wouldn't know every
African nation right or our standards
may be too high i don't know if i said
is Gabon a real country does everybody
immediately know that it is or do you
have to think about it I don't know the
answer to that the United States is very
big lots of people never leave the
United States in their lives because it
is such a big country in other parts of
the world people speak more languages
because of necessity it makes sense
maybe in other countries people also
have a better geographic understanding
because countries are smaller if you're
in Europe you very easily just get on a
train in an hour you can be in a
different country so I don't know the
answer should the average person from
the Czech Republic know where Kansas is
on a map should every American know that
Wakanda is not a country I don't know I
don't know the answer but in any case
nambia definitely one of my favorites
from the trump administration let's take
a quick break make sure to give us a
like on facebook at facebook.com slash
david pakman show I do want to we're
starting to wind down 2019 and after the
break I want to talk a little bit about
sort of a rock bottom that was hit in
2019 in one particular area and I also
want to talk about something very
unsavory happening with the screening
out of white nationalists in the United
States military across all branches
those stories are coming up next one of
our sponsors is privacy calm they're
giving you $5 when you sign up for their
completely free service at privacy calm
slash Pakman I've been using privacy for
a little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
any time you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity
theft and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy calm slash
Pakman